[Music]
there it is fourth floor again mr.
O'Brien it is so exciting to have you
here in San Diego I'm a big fan of
entertainment of all kinds this is kind
of the biggest celebrity we've had here
since I think comic-con 2007 Michael
Chiklis really he's great it's very good
you know some people like the Hulk when
I'm at the thing man myself
oh I do think you have to choose you
hear some people say I like the Hulk and
I think take a position you know hey
while you're here you got to go to the
Naval Base you got to do that promise me
you're gonna do that I don't know if
I'll have time and Sea World right you
got to go to Seabrook I heard they got
rid of a they got rid of the whales yeah
I did hear that because one of those
whales gonna do now you know there's not
a lot of opportunities for whales that
was a good job for them
hey you know where else you can go
though is Legoland they've been to
Legoland okay well here's the problem
you literally cannot get in there if
you're an adult just going alone without
a kid they won't let you in is that
crazy control the position to have to
find a kid so you can get in and I can
find you a kid like if you need a cab
two different kids one was getting a
little old
this is it this is it we got off the
elevator right there that's right you're
gonna be right behind the elevator so
why did we go all the way
oh the card isn't great with left-hand
turns I just prefer to do it right it'll
be just circle
I'm really tired I just love to get
inside he must be tired yeah do you have
a key yeah a lot of the bellhops I have
a key that they get into all the rooms
they don't give me one anymore
I had one what did you do it's not
something I'm super proud of is
Frederick Frederick hey listen if you
need anything just pick up your phone
dial 9 and then star and then 7:00 7:00
and then hang up and then pick it up
again and then 9 again and then three or
four sixes and then wait like a minute
and I should pick up once I'm on my
break or unless that doesn't work it
might not work I'm just gonna go in yeah
all right yeah have a good night's sleep
you're gonna like this room terrific
thank you so much and we'll see you
later
yeah you want me to come in and help you
turn on your fireplace or anything no I
got it my store thank you good night
sleep good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right sorry to bug you but I thought
you might like some ice I think I'm good
thank you
it really does a great job keeping
things cold that's what ice is kind of
famous for but I think I don't need ice
okay sorry to bother you Toblerone I'm
really not a Toblerone guy but thank you
are you sure this is from my own private
stash
I know thank you do you need it I know
I'm just gonna go number one okay hey
mr. O'Brien
look tired and I need to sleep policy
yeah I D right no I don't know I D huh
that's all everybody knows that face
you